I'm Laura Ingram and this is Ingram
angle and thank you for being with us
tonight as always
leaks and losing streaks that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now we know that while the entire press
Corps in the political class were
obsessed with the Trump mar-lago
documents case
the Biden Administration allowed the
United States to be subject to one of
the most disastrous Intel leaks in U.S
history
roughly a hundred pages of documents
that we know of were posted online
revealing critical military assessments
of friends and foes alike
such as U.S efforts to spy on its allies
Israel and South Korea the degree to
which the U.S has penetrated Russia's
government and that Ukraine will fall
well short of its counter-offensive
goals at retaking Russian occupied
territory whoops
well my friends this is devastating and
it tells the world that once again we
can't keep our own house in order our
own Secrets secure
now even axios tonight one of the
establishments most loyal supporters in
the media just posted a story admitting
that the leak is swiftly unfurling into
a debacle for the Biden Administration
which is struggling to provide answers
to Congress the public and U.S allies
and it also tells us that Biden's
triumphant confidence in Ukraine two
months ago well was a total lie
Ukraine continues to defend itself
against the Russian Onslaught and
launched counter-offensive of its own
President Putin's craving lust for land
and power will fail
and the Ukrainian people's love for
their country will prevail
and of course none of this will stop the
bite Administration and its enablers
from distorting the reality in Ukraine
as they've done since the beginning
Ukraine makes advances on the ground
retaking territory even as Russia tries
to recalibrate not only will Ukraine
emerge Sovereign and independent uh when
this is over but Moscow will emerge
weaker when Ukraine's forces are giving
a given state-of-the-art weapons from
the West they're putting them to very
good use they know how to win Ukraine is
winning on the battlefield
how are these people still employed
they're they're wrong every single time
now of course you should expect that the
White House and most of the regime media
will do everything that they can to
downplay the significance of this
massive Intel breach
I've been convening senior department
leaders daily on our response
and I've directed an urgent
cross-department effort we have engaged
with allies and Partners at high levels
over the uh the past the past days
including to reassure them about our own
commitment to safeguarding intelligence
it would appear to me though that the
this is not a serious a breach at least
from what we know publicly so far
yeah Clapper clap on clap off
now the argument that the media Outlets
shouldn't be publishing this information
all that downplaying notwithstanding the
argument that the public should know
about this is completely ludicrous
without confirming the validity of the
documents this is information that has
no business in the public domain it has
no business if you don't mind me saying
on the pages of of uh front pages of
newspapers or on television it is not
intended for public consumption and it
should not be out there
news flash John John
the info is already out there our allies
our adversaries they already have it but
the United States the voters are
supposed to not know any of it keep it
from the American people for what reason
exactly
well I'll tell you for what reason to
help Biden's re-election chances
naturally once again we see the Biden
Administration being run by a team of
incompetence
now remember this no one was punished
when they bundled the Afghanistan
withdrawal where 13 service Personnel
were killed after being left as sitting
docks at the Kabula Airport
and the fact is mistake after Mistake by
these buffoons have flattened both our
domestic and our foreign policy position
now remember the elites they don't sweat
what happens to America between now and
2028 as long as Biden is re-elected
they're okay
that is literally all they care about
they don't care certainly if the United
States is humiliated on the world stage
so per usual after one of the worst
violations of our military secrecy no
one will be fired and like the Dobbs
decision we'll never find out who leaked
the documents I mean do you really think
Austin is going to be on the case with
the doj oh please and we're never going
to have the true story about how bad it
really is how many informants went cold
how many agents lives were jeopardized
or even lost
but while the administration can try to
hide the truth from the American people
it can't fool the rest of the world
both our foes and our few remaining
friends know that the United States
under Joe Biden has become sort of a
paper tiger that's lost touch with its
power has lost its Prestige and its
prosperity
that's why you see our former allies
rushing for the exits they know as well
as we do that America's claim to be a
superpower it can't survive much more of
this certainly not not with China ready
to fill the vacuum with its
freedom-crushing Crusades around the
world
so yes we can spy on people
but how helpful does it end up being
when it's all leaked anyway
and as the angle has told you repeatedly
the people Biden has put in charge of
our national security are total and
complete dolts
no if there are other documents that are
that have been online before these are
things that we will find find out as we
continue to investigate there were
somewhere in the in the web uh and uh
and where exactly and who had access at
that point we we don't know we simply
don't know at this point
they're in the web
you might think it's on the web but
they're somewhere in that web the
worldwide
now as far as the angle is concerned the
U.S at this point is essentially
defenseless
now sure we have incredible military
hardware although a lot less than we had
before Iraq for Afghanistan and before
Ukraine
but we don't have those precious
Commodities that seem few and far
between these days
we don't have leaders
so we end up in a situation where the
most powerful Nation on Earth or what we
used to be
didn't have the ability to stop China
from sending balloons to Traverse the
United States
and again no one's ever fired
the entire point of a military remember
we spent about 800 billion dollars a
year in our military the military's
point is to be a deterrent
and right now they're not deterring
anyone
China's worried about the U.S views on
Taiwan as much as
I care about Liz Cheney's views on the
GOP
nevertheless their recent aggressive
drills near Taiwan
they're not just playful prodding
China's fighter jets fly around Taiwan
Skies military ships sail off its Coast
China says it's simulating Precision
attacks on key Targets in Taiwan its
military released this animation showing
missiles fired from land sea and air
into Taiwan two of them explode in
flames
and the best we can do is reciprocate by
having our own military drills with the
Philippines our close Ally in the region
so at this point it is pretty easy to
conclude that Taiwan is almost doomed
but despite what some neocons like John
Bolton suggest I say no troops in Taiwan
nothing at all for Taiwan until we
revoke the most favored nation trade
status for China
it's literally insane to ask American
troops to be in a country at the same
time we're funding an army that is about
to attack that same country
but instead of learning from past
mistakes Biden just stumbles along
when his people can't get China to
return his call which they can't right
now they just beg harder and they look
more desperate
why doesn't he just picked up the phone
and called President tree to say knock
it off the president looks forward to
having another conversation with
president
do that at the appropriate time we'd
like to see this relationship get onto a
better footing and when it's appropriate
for the two leaders to talk then they'll
happen
not being called back they're being
ghosted
now at no level of this Administration
do we find true confidence and most of
the time voters are simply left in the
dark about what's really going on
they'd rather have you focus on things
like Dylan Mulvaney transgender
activists in Tennessee or whether Harry
and Megan are going to Perry's dad's
coronation
they'd rather destroy the entire country
than address real problems in real time
now Trump tried to fix all of this and
was making real progress especially on
trade and on China and for that he was a
real threat to the folks who normally
Run America
the real threat however is in the
possibility that the man who is barely
coherent who shuffles instead of walks
could actually be re-elected in 2024.
so we must insist that the Press
publishes everything
already in the public domain that helps
Americans understand the stakes here
that includes these Intel leaks
the angle warned you about China about
Millie about Austin Chris Ray and yet
too many Suburban women independent
voters in key States they didn't care
the sad truth is that the angle believes
Biden and Company they've already given
up on America they think that the United
States is too far on the hole to climb
out meaning a managed decline is really
the most compassionate Way Forward
and the rest of the world
they see that America is waning our own
allies the second biggest economy in the
EU France is already sided with China
so my friends here's the bottom line
the United States is facing the biggest
geopolitical crisis any of us has seen
in over 40 years
and right now our leaders are completely
incapable of defending our interests
if we the people do not demand better
leadership
if this group is re-elected and given
four more years to damage our interests
the long-term harm to the United States
and to all of us who live here
will be crippling
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else